Film Courage: Do you remember something that
was said to you in one of these UCLA writing
classes which you never forgot?
Patricia Vidal Delgado, Writer/Director: Yes,
definitely.
Richard Walter [recently retired Professor
and Associate and Interim Dean of the UCLA
School of Theater, Film and Television for
40 years] said nobody wants to see the film
of the village of the nice happy people.
I remember that one because it’s so true.
And also he said something which is in Hollywood
all you do is graduate to the next level disappointment.
I think he used the example that you write
the script but it doesn’t sell.
It’s shot but it’s not distributed.
It’s distributed but not in great venues.
So you basically just graduate to the next
level which is very grounding advice that
you are always going to be walking the tightrope
in this industry no matter how well you think
you’re doing you are going to be walking
a tightrope.
Film Courage: Very interesting.
Also how we were saying the European Mindset
of “Just try it and see what happens.”
Do you think that coupled with that piece
of advice has helped you to be like “You
know what, I’ll try it and submit to Sundance.”
For someone’s first feature film, what a
major accomplishment!
[Patricia’s first feature film La Leyenda
Negra premiered in the 2020 Sundance Film
Festival NEXT program].
Patricia: But to always keep your feet on
the ground because that was something that
he would say to us as a screenwriter the secret
to success is self-motivated speculative writing.
If you just sit around and wait for people
to come to you that’s not going to happen.
You just need to have your own engine and
you have to keep moving forward regardless.
Film Courage: At what point when you hear
that did you approach Mr. Reynoso was it at
Compton High School and ask him to work with
you?
Did you hear this advice before?
Patricia: Oh before definitely.
I think that Richard Walter’s class was
one of the first that I took at UCLA for screenwriting.
Film Courage: Do you think people in the class
reacted to this advice?
Maybe I’m more of this old mindset where
people expected to be picked for things and
I don’t think this is the case anymore.
Do you think there was a reaction to people
thinking I have to be the one to drum up excitement
or not?
Some people want to be picked and there is
also a feeling of I’ve arrived if I’m
picked.
If I have to push this out then it must not
be good.
I think that’s an old mindset of I need
to keep working at this and I’m the one
who has to make this happen?
Patricia: Yes, I think definitely I hear every
young creative in LA say all the time is that
‘The Hustle is real.’
You can never get comfortable.
Just because things are good now doesn’t
mean they are going to stay that way so you’ve
really got to just keep working, keep collaborating,
keep making and just stay focused.
Because I’ve had very successful filmmakers
say to me that that reason that I’m still
making films and the colleagues that I worked
with or grew up with are no longer making
films is not because I am more talented than
them.
It’s just I kept going when they gave up,
that’s the difference.
It’s just persistence and focus and drive
and determination.
That is what is going to keep you moving forward.